Anime can get pretty gruesome.
But what horrific shows are worth your time?
Well, from tales of malevolent spirits to
portraits of people shattered into inhumanity,
these are most terrifying anime you can watch.
Go Nagai's Devilman manga has been adapted
more than once, but 2018's Devilman Crybaby
might just be the most terrifying adaptation
of them all.
Directed by Masaaki Yuasa, this version hews
closer to the manga than others and incorporates
Yuasa's trademark character focus, resulting
in a story as emotionally potent as it is
horrifying.
Akira and Ryo, friends since childhood, are
the series' central figures.
Ryo convinces Akira to become the titular
“Devilman” to fight off an ancient race
of demons.
But all is not as it seems, and what unfolds
manages to shock Devilman newbies and diehard
fans alike.
Death, disfigurement, violence, are all on
vivid display here.
The series penultimate episode, Go to Hell,
You Mortals, is an absolute parade of grotesqueries,
wherein beloved characters are mutilated,
killed, and reduced to desecrated body parts.
But Devilman Crybaby's true nightmare is the
gulf that opens between Akira and Ryo, despite
their careful planning, best intentions, and
literally divine power.
This isn't just a horror story about man's
inhumanity to man, but about the destruction
of love itself at the hands of selfishness
and cruelty.
Horror isn't typically considered a beautiful
genre, but Mononoke is a gorgeous series by
anyone's estimation.
Consisting of 12 episodes, Mononoke tells
the story of a nameless medicine seller who
hunts mononoke spirits across feudal Japan.
Mononoke can't be easily slain, however.
The medicine seller must first understand
the form they take, and why they took it,
before he can dispatch them.
What results is an anime of uncommon psychological
depth.
Human nature is the source of all the scares
in Mononoke, and as such, the lines between
good and bad are profoundly blurred.
The series’ visuals, which resemble 2D paper
cut-outs, intensify this horizontal approach
to horror.
There's no locale that looks "normal," and
as such, terror creeps in with rare subtlety.
Everything from ukiyo-e woodblocks to Art
Nouveau is incorporated into Mononoke's style,
and you can't help but marvel at its aesthetic
flourishes as a grisly scene unfolds.
But that's the point of the anime.
Serial Experiments Lain follows Lain Iwakura,
a 14-year-old girl living in suburban Japan,
who has her quiet life upended by an email
from a dead student.
The student claims not to have actually died,
but instead abandoned her physical form to
live within "the Wired."
Over the course of 13 tense episodes, Lain
goes from introverted girlhood to outright
omnipotence, in a world where the boundary
between the material and the virtual has frayed
to nothing.
Serial Experiments Lain is, first and foremost,
a work of science fiction, but it commits
so wholeheartedly to exploring the possibilities
of artificial intelligence that it becomes
a work of profound horror.
Reality, Lain argues, is a thing people agree
on, and if that consensus can be manipulated,
reality will be altered.
Lain and the audience alike are granted no
quarter as the anime delves into the nature
of a world ruled by inhuman intelligence whose
influence can't be stopped.
Every time Lain sits at her desk, her slim
figure dwarfed by the reef of screens, the
viewer understands that the world is changing
in a way we aren't prepared for.
Satoshi Kon's Perfect Blue is among the most
influential anime to ever exist.
Madonna incorporated clips of it into her
2001 Drowned World tour.
A Director Darren Aronofsky remade a scene
from Perfect Blue in Requiem for a Dream.
Why this far-flung influence?
It’s simple; Perfect Blue is a masterpiece
of dread.
Mima, our protagonist, has just left a pop
idol group to become a serious actress.
But as threatening faxes pour in and a website
entitled "Mima's Room" — containing diary
entries purportedly written by Mima herself
— gains momentum, Mima realizes not all
is as it seems.
The events of Perfect Blue are themselves
horrific, but it's Kon's dizzying approach
to their portrayal that make Perfect Blue
the nightmare it is.
Frantic cuts disorient the viewer, odd scene
changes mimic Mima's increasingly disordered
mind, and mirrors, screens, and windows refract
a world that has lost its meaning.
Mima descends into an underworld of illusion,
and the viewer has only her perspective to
rely on, one that draws into question the
reliability of reality.
There's a culprit held to account at the end
of Perfect Blue, but their actions are only
part of the story.
The real terror, in Mima's mind and the viewer's,
lies in her world's collapse.
Corpse Party's long, bloody history began
in 1996, as a simple PC video game.
Today, the Corpse Party franchise encompasses
manga spin-offs, live-action films, and drama
CDs.
Corpse Party: Tortured Souls, is 2013's anime
adaptation of the beloved series.
Years before the series' beginning, Heavenly
Host Elementary School was the site of a series
of brutal kidnappings and killings.
Though it was razed, a new high school was
built in its place and filled with teenagers
who don't understand the malevolent psychic
energy that surrounds them, until they find
themselves trapped in a nightmare version
of Heavenly Host.
Corpse Party is a brutal, bloody series that
revels in the macabre.
It's got spilled innards, severed tongues,
and bifurcated bodies.
If you can stomach this, it's a satisfyingly
savage tale of the past's long shadows and
the youth forced to grow up within them.
The trauma they've inherited isn't their own,
but it’s their job to process it anyway.
Shiki, which chronicles the destruction of
a small town by the inhuman monsters that
live in the mansion on the town's outskirts,
is a classic vampire story.
The shiki are hypnotic, undying figures with
inhuman drives, as utterly unknowable as they
are eerily similar to everyday people.
Those who are killed are reborn as shiki.
Megumi, the first to die, goes from being
a small-town girl with big-city dreams to
being an undead killer with disdain for her
hometown.
This might sound familiar, but what makes
Shiki a truly memorable work of horror is
the truth of the shiki themselves.
At heart, the shiki just want to build a peaceful
home.
The shiki's actions are vile, but the anime
never shies from the truth of their tragic
situation.
They exist, they must feed, and they're trying
to find a way to do both with a minimum of
cruelty.
The impossibility of reconciling these things
is what makes Shiki such a resonant horror
story.
No Longer Human began as a 1948 novel by legendary
author Osamu Dazai, and it's a story as powerful
as it is challenging to adapt.
Yet 2009 saw that accomplished when Aoi Bungaku
a 12-episode anime series featuring adaptations
of popular Japanese literature devoted the
first four episodes of its run to animating
No Longer Human.
Though Aoi Bungaku takes liberties with its
source material, the core conceit remains
intact.
Protagonist Yozo, feels completely detached
from everything that makes one genuinely human.
Watching him disastrously fail to connect
is a truly harrowing and relatable portrait
of brokenness.
His life might not be anything like the viewer's,
but as in the original novel, almost anyone
can see a little of themselves in Yozo.
That's what No Longer Human forces us to view
through Yozo's inhumanity.
In this, he's far more human than he realizes,
and that's the most terrifying thing of all.
Years before the events of Another, a student
in Yomiyama Middle School suddenly died.
Her classmates, reeling with grief, pretended
as though she hadn't died at all, to the point
of reserving her seat at graduation.
This culminated in the deceased classmate's
mysterious appearance in the class's graduation
photo.
Years later, a boy named Koichi begins his
time in the same class late, due to illness,
and he discovers that something is amiss.
Misaki, a quiet classmate, is entirely ignored
by the other students.
And then, one by one, Koichi's peers start
dying.
Misaki is the only one who isn't surprised
by these tragedies, and only she understands
how to stop them.
The anime's moments of violence, terror, and
dread make it the sort of nightmare any horror
fan can enjoy, but their true power lies beyond
brief thrills.
They're the pillars of the story's central
tragedy.
The class is locked within a cycle of grief
that can only be broken by that most crucial
thing: acceptance.
Their inability to do so is the series' truest
nightmare of all.
To be young and in love.
Happy Sugar Life addresses the virtues of
this sublime state, only to confront the viewer
with the reality of its starring couple Satou,
a teenage girl with a hard-luck past, and
Shio, the kind-hearted eight-year-old that
Satou keeps locked in her apartment.
Satou will do anything to conceal and protect
the "happy sugar life" she believes she's
created for her and Shio.
Theirs is a love of pristine purity, according
to Satou, and there's no evil she won't commit
in her devotion to its preservation.
Happy Sugar Life never glories in the details
of Satou's grisliest acts.
This anime chills the viewer with a vision
of just how people can twist each other into
monsters.
Satou, exposed to only the most dysfunctional
relationship models as a child, believes that
kidnapping a child is excusable in the name
of true love.
But it is Shio's character arc that really
terrifies.
Having known only abandonment and violence
so far in her short life, she can't recognize
Satou for the monster she is, nor identify
herself as an individual beyond what Satou
projects upon her.
What results is a story about how entirely
people can destroy the ones they love and
just how invisible the process can be.
An alternative ending to Neon Genesis Evangelion’s
controversial final episode, The End of Evangelion
shows us the apocalypse.
NERV, the paramilitary group responsible for
the Evangelion units that our heroes pilot,
is being used by its commander, Gendo Ikari,
to hasten the end of the world.
He succeeds, though not as he would've liked.
Prickly Asuka is disemboweled.
Quiet Rei attains Biblical power and joins
all of humanity into a single consciousness.
Protagonist Shinji survives, yet the story
ends on a shot of him and Asuka alone in the
ruined world.
It’s implied that humanity might reform,
but in that moment, Shinji attempts to strangle
Asuka to death.
When he fails, Asuka mutters the last line
of the film,
"Kimochi warui,"
which is most often translated as, "I feel
sick," or, "How disgusting."
The End of Evangelion is possibly about hope,
but mostly, it's about the venality of the
world, the corruption of the powerful, and
the inevitability of decay.
Shadow Star Narutaru begins as a tale about
a pigtailed everygirl and her mysterious alien
friend, Hoshimaru.
You might be thinking that this sounds like
Digimon or Cardcaptor Sakura, a story of youngsters
and their unlikely companions saving the world
with their supernatural bond.
This is very much by design.
Hoshimaru is adorable, Shiina is a cheery
charmer, and the opening theme features purposefully
childlike drawings of the cast alongside their
alien friends.
It's sweet, it's bright, and it features a
lot of harmonica.
Somehow, Shadow Star Narutaru begins this
way and then ends, 13 episodes later, as one
of the most graphically disturbing anime series
of the 2000s.
Characters are beheaded, impaled, forced to
eat maggots, have their severed heads mounted
on dolls, and experience a whole host of other
grisly horrors too graphic to be described.
Shadow Star Narutaru is, in the end, a series
that absolutely glories in the worst things
people can do to each other.
Watching it is dizzying, as moments of grotesque
horror are often juxtaposed against scenes
of peaceful daily life, to say nothing of
Shiina, whose blue-haired perkiness becomes
more and more discordant as the series darkens.
Its abrupt ending only makes the series more
upsetting.
Shadow Star Narutaru charms, horrifies, and
then, somewhat inexplicably, ends.
The viewer is left to absorb all that unfolded
on screen with little in the way of explanation
and definitely nothing resembling comfort.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
anime are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.